[Music]
what does a vector that's right
previously we had seen that a vector is
a quantity that has magnitude as well as
direction for example let's say an
object is displaced from a point A to a
point B which is three meters away from
it in a direction 20 degrees east of
North
so here the displacement of the object
is a vector quantity the magnitude of
the displacement vector here is three
meters and its direction is 20 degrees
east of North as we saw earlier we can
represent a vector by an arrow so the
displacement vector is represented by an
arrow with its initial point as a and
its terminal point as B it's denoted
like this with an arrow above the
letters or we can also denote it by a
single letter like this the length of
the arrow represents the magnitude of
the displacement vector which is denoted
like this and the direction of the arrow
head represents the direction of the
vector so we see that we can represent a
vector in general by an arrow now here
are a few vectors on the screen with
different magnitudes and directions
notice that these vectors are parallel
to each other while these vectors have a
common initial point now obviously a
question arises in our mind can we
compare two vectors or when can we say
that two vectors are equal to each other
in this video we will understand this
and we'll also look at different types
of vectors first let's consider these
vectors we can see that they all have a
common initial point o2 or more vectors
having the same initial point are called
Co initial vectors so here vectors o M
or N and O L are all Co initial vectors
now consider these Veck
to us here they're all parallel to each
other or we can say that they are
parallel to this line if two or more
vectors are parallel to the same line
even though they have different
magnitudes and directions they are
called collinear vectors does all these
vectors are collinear vectors now
consider vector a B and vector C D they
both are directed in the same direction
and have the same magnitude so we can
say that vector a B is equal to vector C
D two vectors are said to be equal if
they have the same magnitude and
direction regardless of the position of
the initial points notice this important
point it tells us that it's
insignificant where the initial points
of the vectors are if they're equal to
each other so according to this we can
move a vector parallel to its position
without affecting its magnitude and
direction for example we can make two
copies of vector a B by moving it
parallel e in this direction or moving
it in the same direction like this here
all the three vectors will be equal to
each other such vectors are called free
vectors that is parallel displacement of
vectors gives us equivalent vectors one
advantage of this is that it makes it
easier to compare two vectors now
consider the vectors a B RS and UV let's
move them parallel to the positions
without affecting their magnitudes and
directions such that they originate from
a single point can you see now it's much
easier to compare the directions and the
magnitudes of these vectors with respect
to each other now let me ask you a
question what will be the negative of a
vector for example let's take the vector
CD here we know a vector is defined by
two things its magnitude that is its
strength and its direction so the
negative of the vector CD is a vector
which has the same magnitude as that of
CD and it's Direction is opposite to
that of CD so vector DC will be the
negative of the vector CD and it's
denoted like this
also notice that vector EF will be the
negative of vector CD yes the magnitude
of vector EF is the same as that of
vector CD and it's directed in the
opposite direction to that of vector CD
so vector EF will be the negative of
vector CD does we saw here when our two
vectors equal to each other and also
what's the negative of a vector now can
you tell me if we can add two vectors
does this seem possible to you we will
see this in the next lesson
just stay updated and to keep learning
such interesting things do subscribe to
our Channel
[Music]